pft's own mike florio back here on the
show how are you mike doing great rich
how are you playing i'm doing better so
uh
what's the uh what's what's what's the
latest on the desean watson uh trade is
that popping that popping out of the
toaster for the storm what do you think
the calm before the storm i think i
don't know i've been trying to
rattle the cages a little bit to see
what may be going on today haven't heard
anything back yet the owners are in new
york city steven ross was asked about it
and wisely said nothing the dolphins
owner can't say anything about a player
under contract with another team unless
he ends up potentially finding himself
in trouble for tampering so
you know he'll be in the room with cal
mcnair the owner of the texans david
tepper floating around the panthers
owner and the dolphins and the panthers
continue to be the two teams that people
are paying the most attention to i got
75 25 dolphins over panthers but i think
it's going to get done by next tuesday
you know i don't know this but i'm
surmising based upon the various things
i've heard the things that people like
nick casario the texans gm and david
cully the texans coach have said this
season they talk about taking it all day
to day i think at some point somebody
now they could renege on this but i
think somebody told watson they were
trading them before the deadline and i'm
going to be surprised very surprised at
this point if it doesn't go down what do
you mean somebody told them just like
hey sit tight bear with us don't show up
and say here i am i want to play because
you can't put a guy on paid leave
unless he's okay with it that was the
blow back to the terrell owens situation
from o5 when the eagles eventually sent
him home for the rest of the year and
say we'll send you your paycheck just
get the hell out of here keyshawn
johnson had that happen to him a few
years earlier you can't do that anymore
you gotta have grounds to suspend the
guy without pay you can do it for up to
four weeks and that's it you can't just
pay a guy to go home so he's got to be
on board with it so you know if they
don't trade him by next tuesday and i'm
not saying that he's going to do this
but in theory he could show up on
wednesday and say i'm ready to play some
football and that's not what they want
right so what's why isn't he on the
commissioner's exempt list already is it
because the texans have him on the
texans exempt list and he's got them uh
on the desean watson exempt list you
know um or or there's no grounds for it
just yet which clears the way for a
trade
a situation where make no decision until
you absolutely positively have to and
i've had this told to me a couple of
different times when i've poked around
with the league office because the
dolphins actually contacted the league
late august when this all first bubbled
up because it looked like it was going
to happen there was that moment where
the texans had to decide are we going to
actually devote a roster spot to deshaun
watson and have 52 guys on the team what
are we going to do with deshawn watson
well if you trade him you got your
53-man roster free and clear and it
almost happened then texans wanted more
than what the dolphins were willing to
do but the league made it clear then
we're not telling anything we haven't
decided we're not going to decide until
we have to and whatever the
circumstances are rich at the time he's
traded whatever is going on with the
criminal cases there are 10 criminal
complaints that yet to be presented
officially to a grand jury they will be
at some point
maybe he'll be indicted maybe he won't
we don't know how that's going to play
out but then there were the 22 civil
cases they almost settled them a few
months back
the talks broke down over the issue of
whether or not the settlements would be
confidential you don't get to that point
if you don't have a loose understanding
as to what the payment would be that's
not how it works you know you don't jump
forward to other issues on the docket if
you don't have an understanding of what
the payment will be so those deals could
be done at any time 22 cases could be
resolved like that and if the
commissioner is considering what to do
with deshaun watson and he's resolved
the 22 cases to the satisfaction of the
22 women who have made their complaints
that may counsel against putting him on
paid leave while they wait to see what
happens with the
the criminal situation but at some point
the dust settles on the legal stuff and
that's when watson faces a potential
suspension without pay like what
happened to ben roethlisberger in 2010
he was sued once he was accused another
time
never charged with a crime but he ended
up being suspended six games reduced to
four i think that whoever gets to sean
watson has to expect at some point he's
going to be suspended without pay for
the loose understanding of six games and
also he's the one back in you know the
spring who is insisting on having no
confidentiality right it's not like he's
the one saying i'm gonna settle
everything and nothing will ever get out
he wants everything public at least
that's what he was saying then has that
stance changed in your estimation or no
cause that's another thing a team that's
gonna want uh to acquire and would wanna
know like you know what is gonna come
out right like what are we going to now
own
uh
through
acquiring this player right the usual
stance that the party who is writing the
check
will take in a case like this is to
insist on
confidentiality because whether it's a
corporation
whoever yeah and usually it's
corporation i mean you know
most of the cases are brought against
somebody with money yes or an insurance
policy otherwise the lawyer's wasting
his or her time they always told us in
law school there's three things
liability damages and collectibility you
can have a great case and you can put on
the blackboard if they have blackboards
anymore all sorts of dollars that were
lost but if you can't get any of it it
doesn't matter it's a waste of your time
so the corporations that end up being
sued
they don't want
people to find out how much they paid to
make a case go away because that's an
invitation for more of the same so they
always want confidentiality
watson didn't want it here his lawyer
rusty harden has fought against
confidentiality the lawyer for the
plaintiffs wanted confidentiality and
that sends a message
that
whatever the amount
is going to be
it's not all that much grand scheme of
things and the lower the amount the
easier it is to create the perception
that he just
he just had his reckoning on this
gave the individuals
some form of compensation but ultimately
not the kind of payment he would make if
he was guilty of some sort of heinous
conduct and i think that's an important
distinction that he's the one that's
saying i want all of this to be open
because it is almost always the other
way around but you think one week from
today we're gonna see deshaun watson in
a different uniform and and then
he will be ready to play like let's just
say it's miami in in their week nine
contest
it's entirely possible yeah against the
texans it's entirely possible he goes i
mean it's entirely possible now how long
does it take to get him ready i don't
know
will he be put on paid leave we don't
know i i don't
think he will be
but we just don't know the league hasn't
sat down to make a decision now they've
interviewed a lot of the individuals who
have made their complaints about desean
watson and you know there were some
comments from tony busby the lawyer who
represents the 22 individuals that they
thought they were disrespected
by the league and and or by the
investigators and
you know sometimes that happens when
you're asked tough questions about your
version of events and you don't like
being pushed and you don't like holes in
your story being challenged and you
start to think they don't believe me and
they're just you know they're just
asking
tough questions and if they don't like
tough questions when they get questioned
by rusty harden
in their depositions and at trial it's
going to be a hundred times worse but
that that made me wonder whether or not
they came out of that interaction
getting the sense that the league maybe
didn't believe them the way that they
thought the league would or should so
maybe the league isn't all that troubled
and maybe they will let him play but you
know if he's physically ready if they
can get him up to speed in theory he
could play as soon as week nine but boy
that's a lot to ask for especially if
the trade doesn't happen until next
tuesday now if it happens today tomorrow
you got a little extra time to get him
ready for week nine and and and uh
that's why i won't be surprised if it
happens this week if i'm caserio i delay
it to the last possible second i don't
want to see it i don't want to see him
oh you don't want to see him week nine
oh you're absolutely right it's not that
they have a great chance of winning the
game anyway but you don't want sean
for his first game of the new team to be
sticking it to your team wow mike florio
pro football talk here on the rich eisen
show walk me through the protocol that
devonte adams is gonna have to
go through to potentially get on the
field on thursday even though that
appears highly unlikely yeah vaccinated
player tests positive and the vaccinated
players get tested once a week if you're
positive you have to have two negatives
at least 24 hours apart and from monday
to thursday that's a tall order now we
haven't seen any news of further
positives today they split the teams up
into three different chunks for the
weekly test most important players would
be i assume as early as possible so you
have a chance of turning it around but i
don't think there's been anybody who was
vaccinated who tested positive who was
back within five or six days they've all
missed at least one game whether it's a
coach or whether it's a player so i'd be
stunned if devante adams is available on
thursday night and they don't have
defensive coordinator joe berry either
the question is between now and thursday
will there be more who test positive you
know people have asked me rich well is
there a chance the game gets postponed i
don't get the impression the league has
any appetite whatsoever this year to
delay any game
for any reason and i don't know what the
magic number is between 11 healthy
players and 46
but somewhere in there you know there's
a minimum that they'll go forward with
but when you got 69 total guys available
it's going to take a lot to get to the
point where a team would get some sort
of a dispensation to not proceed with it
again well i mean last year without a
vaccine if you remember thursday night
green bay took on san francisco and san
francisco was you know maybe pulling
somebody from
you know uh their their training staff
to go suit up as a wide receiver i mean
i remember that that was
that was wild but the league still went
ahead and made them play you know the
broncos versus the saints i i don't know
that that would be that would be a
surprise to me um what about what is
speaking to san francisco uh what i i'll
just open it up what's happening there
what are you what are you hearing about
about the coach and about the the
quarterback and about trey lance and
this team that's two and four right now
and we're already talking about how two
and five seattle the division's history
um that's becoming an object that's not
nearly as close as they'd like to appear
in the rearview mirror of arizona and
los angeles what's going on with the
49ers you know it's amazing it occurred
to me last night when the seahawks lost
to the saints that the seahawks and the
49ers had that epic last game of the
season game number 256 on nbc to end the
2019 season with the number one seed in
the balance in the nfc and now the 49ers
are two and four and the seahawks are
two and five less than two years later
it just shows you how quickly things can
change and with the 49ers i personally
think
that they are scarred by the fact that
they passed on patrick mahomes in 2017
and that they said no thank you to tom
brady in 2020 when he wanted to come
home and play for the 49ers they're like
now we're good with jimmy garoppolo they
saw both of those guys playing against
each other in super bowl 55 and i just
think they
they they got a little desperate and
they outsmarted themselves i think they
would have been in on matthew stafford
if they'd had the chance that deal got
done before they even knew what was
going on they made the call to get aaron
rodgers the night before the draft even
though they'd already given up
three first-round picks to get in
position two first-round picks plus the
12th overall to get in position to take
quarterback with number three and then
they end up taking a guy who everyone
regards as a project like okay we we
need an upgrade over jimmy garoppolo we
need somebody better than him and they
give up all that stuff and they get a
guy who's not going to be ready
so it's going to be jimmy until the
guy's ready i just think that it's just
an inherent mess at the quarterback
position and now tray lance is already
injured and who knows how much longer
jimmy garoppolo is going to hold on and
i i'm concerned that
that
we're going to see john lynch on a very
hot seat because kyle shanahan runs the
show and i think before he would be gone
usually the gm gets to hire two coaches
before the gm's in trouble
in san francisco the coach is in charge
and he may
he may to save himself
have to find a new gm who does a better
job at helping him set the table because
they've just made a bunch of bad
decisions they have a very good team but
they made a bunch of bad decisions and
if you take out 2019 rich their five
years have been a major disappointment i
think peter king said earlier today they
are eight games under 500 even with that
spectacular 2019 season mike florio here
on pro football talk couple minutes left
with him right here on the rich eisen
show so um what is the topic of
discussion uh at the nfl
fall meeting with the membership as it's
referred to what is happening what's on
the docket there today well you know the
sunday ticket thing is very fascinating
because there's momentum toward directv
keeping the satellite side of it and
someone else having the streaming side
of it one of the big issues there is the
bars out there and the restaurants
they're not equipped to stream like
homes are and individuals walk around
with their phones they need that
satellite delivery to have the maximum
exposure in those settings so i could
see
a hybrid come out of that where it's
satellite for directv and streaming for
someone else and people are very
interested in what happens with the
sunday ticket package you know the
elephant in the room is the wft
situation
and
peter king suggested in football morning
in america that they won't talk about it
very much in open sessions because you
know somebody may blab
but i can't imagine there won't be
questions of owners there already have
been some woody johnson was asked about
it and he politely punted but you know
the commissioner he does his end of
meetings press conference and it'll be
interesting to see how aggressive the
questioning is with all the different
wrinkles all the angles who who ordered
the code red on john gruden why did it
happen during the season not before or
after what are you doing about the
congressional inquiry there's a lot of
meat there and and i'll be fascinated to
see how many questions he gets on that
on that broader topic of the
investigation and the email leakage
wasn't the gruden weren't the gruden
emails in question part of a separate um
litigation that were redacted or is it
possible that that's where those emails
came from and what are also you hearing
about what gruden's next move is going
to be i i can't imagine that he's not
going to
just that he's just going to sit and say
nothing to nobody forever right like
what are you hearing about that about
those two subject matters well hbo sent
around an email last week with uh
some quotes from their real sports
podcast where andrea kramer explained
that a producer there called up john
gruden out of the blue
and he said the truth will come out of
course the most common reaction that is
why
it already has come out
but i think there's a different truth
he's possibly referring to as to how
this all went down and why it happened
when it happened in the middle of a
season when
at the latest the league knew about
these in june now my understanding is
while going through the emails the 650
000 emails that the league says we're
all sent to and from bruce allen and
that's a lot of emails that's 178 on
average per day every day for 10 years
but but assuming that's true regardless
while going through those they found the
gruden emails
and i'm told by june they were fully
aware of the contents they may have been
aware of them before then and just
didn't act on it but then the
commissioner asked some executives to
kind of put it all together and give
them a summary and right before
the first one leaked to the wall street
journal the league had decided to send a
packet to the raiders like hey what are
you going to do about this
but the fact that all came to head
during the season is just if you're a
raiders fan now even though they're 2-0
without gruden it has to be troubling
this could have happened you know in
theory it could happen in january and
you go hire a new coach and you just
move on or you just hold it until after
the season you let gruden get through
the year and then you hold on why did it
happen in october and maybe that's one
of the things gruden's gonna try to get
to the bottom of and why him why not
anybody else whose emails may be caught
up in that trove that they refuse to
show us even though we've seen enough of
it that
i think it's easy to make the argument
that we should maybe see all of it mike
appreciate the time we'll see you on pro
football talk every single morning on
nbc sports on peacock appreciate you
calling into the westwood one halftime
show yesterday on this show today as
well thanks rich great talking to you
pop back at you that's mike flower at
pro football talk
must follow
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here